here's David chair
you need money we're changing the
ventilators here at the corner bookstore
I want to welcome you all here for a
very special evening cross a welcoming
book TV here which makes it even extra
special for the few people here that
don't know David I'll just give a little
brief background you have a BA from
Brandeis and MFA from NYU in film
production and he has been an astrologer
and screenwriter in the New York native
this is his first book this is the
publication date doesn't get any better
than that join me in welcoming David Jer
[Applause]
thanks everybody for coming out and so I
want to talk about the setting for this
book and I want to talk about the story
itself but I also want to make the point
that this period is going to sound very
distant it's going to sound very credit
it's going to sound like a time where
society was very credulous and
superstitious and it's going to sound
like a period which was very long ago
and but in fact in 1983 the University
of Chicago took a poll and it showed
that 27% of Americans believed they were
in touch with the dead and this was the
National voting Research Center I
believe and so it wasn't about asking
people if they felt they were having
imaginary conversations with the dead
you know the question was do you
genuinely believe that you are in touch
with this carnot spirits that you are
hearing from them
and as I mentioned 27% of the people
said that they were which would have
translated to about 50 million Americans
that believe that they were in touch
with the dead so that was in 1983 this
period I'm writing about it during a
job's agent in 1920s the other thing
I'll say about how close that that error
essentially is is that when I was a kid
I remember there was an ice cream parlor
that was opening near me some of my
friends from Rhode Island are here and
they probably remember that ice cream
store and and I was sitting there was
the grand opening and there was this old
man that was being introduced to all the
patrons and he came to me and he shook
my hand and he said hi I'm Jack Dempsey
now Jack Dempsey was one of the three or
four great icons of the Jazz Age and you
know it was sort of sad what he was
doing at that point
but I'm only illustrating the story too
to mention again that you know when two
lives can intersect and that way you're
not talking about distant era so the
time period I'm writing about the 1920s
was a time where without question the
most recognizable most famous American
in the world of the magician this was in
between the death of Teddy Roosevelt in
1919 and it was before Lindbergh had
flown across the Atlantic and in those
intervening years
Houdini's fame
sorry that's good
in those intervening years
Houdini's fame was really as a attacks
and as I mentioned he was he was the
most famous American on the planet and
the other thing that I'll say about this
era is that there are times certainly in
the summer of 1924 where a medium was on
the front page of national newspapers
like the New York Times certainly in
August of 1924 more seldom the President
of the United States and it was a time
when this one particular medium that the
Witch of Lime Street had the following
of a religious leader and in fact she
was the avatar of a religious movement
called spiritualism
this was a religion that really had only
one tenant the belief that it was
possible to communicate with the dead
through the sentence and what we'll talk
more about that but essentially what it
was for the first time in 2000 years
mediums were conducting the rites of a
religion so you know all these things
were happening and happening in 1920s
but if you really want to understand the
1920s you have to go back just a few
years earlier and in the early part of
the 20th century there is the sense that
Science and Technology were going to
conquer every human ill you know all
these these terrible diseases like
cholera and smallpox and typhoid you
know they developed by destroying
vaccines for them so all these these
terrible epidemics that had occurred
these plague that had occurred through
the ages were no longer as much of an
issue in the Western world tuberculosis
which is killed 24 think 25% of the
people who died in 1800s they were even
making strides in you know to arrest
tuberculosis so the other thing that was
happening was that that there were there
hadn't been a major war in Europe for
since the franco-prussian war which is
about 50 years prior to
19:14 there hadn't been a wait major
ward in America in longer than Matt
since the Civil War so there is the
sense that the world was moving into
this new enlightened period where there
wasn't going to be war anymore at least
not major war where sicknesses were
going to be conquered by science and
technology it was a new rational age and
there was this sense that people were
really changing that you know the world
was progressing that that things were
just improving and certainly in those
areas for the better and then what
happens in 1914 you have the worst war
anybody could it could it could imagine
and it was this war where where people
just weren't prepared for the
devastation that you know the new
weapons and the new technology could
instill and could cause and so you you
have battles where it for instance the
Battle of Somme where the British lost
twenty thousand men and twenty thousand
dead in the first day of battle and you
know you had by the end of the war you
had about a twenty million dead English
had lost the gentleman had lost the
generation France have lost the
generation Germany has lost a generation
and just when it looked like it couldn't
get any worse then you had this
influenza epidemic which took even more
people than the war these lorentz
epidemic took about 100 million lives
and again it was a disproportionate
amount of young people who died so you
have this collective yearning now to
really understand - I understand if it
was possible to communicate with these
dead souls you know the Western world
was was bereaved and you had a certain
well - people in particular - men in
particular with lost sons or it not war
and if you were an upper-class English
men and your son was fighting in the war
your son was dead I mean that was
basically all there was to it that the
life expectancy of a field officer and
the first one war was was about six
weeks and if you were an upper-class
Englishman it meant
son was an officer so Sir Arthur Conan
Doyle who you probably know him as the
creator of Sherlock Holmes you know
that's sort of the personification of
rationalism and adoptive thinking well
Conan Doyle was also the leader the de
facto leader of the spiritualist
movement and again this religion that's
based on the idea that the dead can be
reached and you try to communicate with
them through the seance
so Doyle had written a number of books
you know he wasn't writing about
Sherlock Holmes anymore he's writing
books called the new revelation and the
vital question Doyle had not only lost
his son Doyle had lost his brother by
the end of the war to the in Florence
epidemic
he's lost his his wife's brother as well
he'd lost his nephew essentially every
male that that from Doyle's family died
during the war and but he claimed that
he didn't breed them because he
genuinely believed that he was in touch
with them through the seance that he was
able to communicate with them through
the seance so he was one of the two most
influential members leaders of the
spiritualist movement the other was Sir
Oliver live so Oliver Lodge was probably
one of the two or three most respected
scientists in England you know he was
almost like their Thomas Edison in a way
because he was also a great inventor he
invented the the spark ignition
he sent radio waves before Marconi he
was a really really important figure his
son Raymond died during the war again he
believed he was in touch with Raymond's
spirit he wrote a book called Raymond
that they say was more popular in
England than the Bible during World War
one because everybody wanted to believe
this that you know that it was possible
to communicate with these dead boys and
when somebody like surrounding a lodge
is a respected scientist tells you that
it is possible and Conan Doyle who you
know Conan Doyle he wasn't just a a
writer or an author Conan Doyle was the
face of the British Empire
if Conan Doyle was sort of England
Teddy Roosevelt he was rugged and he was
athletic and and he just you know he was
the loved around the world he he wrote
about the war he was a very respected
columnist he he the British public just
love them they revered him he was
without question the most famous
Englishman in the world least most
recognizable at this time so you have
these two virtuous Victorians these
these famous figures who come out and
they're telling the world that it's
possible to communicate with the dead
and Conan Doyle believes that if
spiritualism is really going to take
hold then you have to bring it to
America so he urges Oliver Lodge you've
never been to America to come to America
Oliver Lodge comes to America and just
like the first day as a Jazz Age in
January 1920 he comes to America and he
starts telling Americans that it's
possible to communicate with that and
you know in America they haven't had the
kind of losses in Europe did they you
know we'd lost people to the epidemic of
course and we'd lost people during the
war but America was not really breathing
and but Lodge more than any single
individual was the person who really
inspired this this Renaissance in
America at that time it's a cult revival
you know he comes to America and a
couple of months later Norman Rockwell
is painting this couple doing a weisia
experiment on the front page of The
Saturday Evening Post you know it's
young couple and they're playing around
with the Ouija board so we became very
popular became a rage
seances became a rage and you know it
was all because Oliver Lodge went across
the country and he sounded very
convincing and people thought that he
presented convincing proof now what's
happening right when Sir Oliver Lodge is
speaking in America
the magician Houdini had come to Europe
Houdini was probably more famous when he
first started out of the magician
when he first achieved any kind of
recognition as a magician it was in
Europe so he was lucky was beloved there
he considered England his his second
home and in January 1920 justice Oliver
Lodge is making his case in America
Houdini comes to England and you know
this was about a little over two years
after the war I'm sorry buddy a little
over a little over a year after the war
and England was still a depleted country
they were still war rationing going on
and you know Houdini is this incredibly
potent vital figure he you know he's the
very personification of American
vitality at the time because you know
America was considered a young country
was still referred to at the New World
England was the old world england was
devastated you know America hadn't
really been depleted in that way and so
Houdini
you know shows up with all this energy
and he said he's sitting box office box
office records in England you know it
seems like he can personally just
energized and and it just has his
magnetism his spirit or just infusing
England with his new energy but what
people don't really recognize is that
Houdini was depressed and you know
Houdini wasn't really unhappy garden he
um his mother had died not long before
the war in 1912 and Houdini he had he
was passionately in love with his mother
and Al Doctorow once referred to
convenience the last the Great Mother
lovers because this was this was just
before Freud was becoming famous in
America so you could write these love
letters to your mother and nobody really
thought anything of it
and so Houdini she was though the light
of his like you know his wife was second
fiddle and so she dies and he never
recovers from that loss and he starts
going to see psychics and mediums and to
see if he can get in touch with her
spirit but you know Houdini knows all
the tricks of mediums because when he
was young the first time he made any
kind of an impact as an entertainer the
first time he started making any kind of
significant II was as a false medium he
had what's called a spook show where he
would basically give these false seances
and use what he called spirit istic
forests to make objects fly around the
room and raise tables he would be tied
up and musical instruments would begin
to play around him so he knew all the
secrets of these mediums but you know he
had this very kind of love-hate
relationship with them because he wanted
to find one who was genuine and so part
of his reason for coming to England is
because he's begun corresponding with
Sir Arthur Conan Doyle and he wants to
see all these English psychics that
Conan Doyle has been recommending and at
Conan Doyle is advocating so Houdini in
Conan Doyle develop this very unusual
friendship but you know Conan Doyle is
this burly idiot I think is about six
foot three it's very impressive and
formidable figure you know the
scotch-irish Knight Houdini was a very
potent but he was very short and you
know he was this Jew from the ghetto and
so they formed this very unlikely
friendship and Houdini starts to attend
seances that that Doyle arranges for him
and then Houdini comes to America comes
back to America and it seems to some
people so he's bought into this because
he starts making a movie that that
really is carrying a spiritual 16 to it
and it seems as though maybe he's bought
into it you know we did he was a movie
star and filmmaker as well as a magician
and escape artists by this time
so then Conan Doyle comes to America and
what if it's Oliver Lodge
planted the seed for this occult revival
in America Conan Doyle you know he just
sets the country on fire he sets
box-office records every place he speaks
Conan Doyle is one of the great public
speakers at this time and you know he
didn't present thing couch things in a
scientifically the way Lodge did but he
spoke from the heart
and he seemed so sincere sincere and
again because he sort of the you know
he's so emblematic of deductive thinking
and rationalism because people some
people called me Sherlock Holmes you
know he had a reputation for being able
to solve these mysteries himself and you
know clearing the names of criminals
who've been wrongfully convicted and
this kind of thing and Americans are
always loved Conan Doyle anyway so he
comes to America and and now you know
the country is just mad for ghosts and
seances and you know this is becoming
this domestic pastime now the the Jazz
Age is also a time where contests were
very becoming very popular and in 1922 I
believe was the first Miss America
pageant and it was also around this time
that there was something called the Nash
nationwide motion picture idea contest
that Cecil B DeMille initiated and what
it was was they put up a lot of money
and Cecil B DeMille who great filmmaker
and the country said give me your best
film idea and I'll make it you know
whoever whoever comes up with the best
idea we're going to give you a lot of
money we're going to make the film using
just so the other the other contests and
it's happened a little bit earlier you
know there was still this reverence for
scientists and science and Einstein came
to America and he was given a ticker
tape parade down Broadway I mean you
know this is a time you know those
things are reserved for great Explorer
the military heroes and you know here's
this little Jewish professor and he
disease you know they're they're
bringing him down Broadway and he just
seems so reticent but you know
no one in America understood anything
about you know exactly what Einstein had
done they just took it on faith that
whatever he did was great and you know
it's just a testament to how caught up
people were and what reverence was was
given to science at that time and so the
Scientific American which was a really
big deal in those days they they were
sort of like a combination of the New
York Times in 60 minutes because they
they were investigative agency and in a
time when technology was becoming so
pervasive and all these new great
inventions there was also a lot of
quackery and people look to the
Scientific American to tell them you
know what was a legitimate invention and
what was really the you know the next
great development around the curve and
you know what was just you know
flim-flam or for instance there was the
this famous doctor at the time named dr.
Albert Abrams who said he could cure
anybody through something called the
dynamize er and that sounds kind of
silly and was this apparatus and he
would do it it takes too long to explain
but he claimed to be able to diagnose
and cure anybody through this very
sketchy kind of apparatus and machine
and people believed it so the Scientific
American investigated him and and they
said there is this much legitimacy to
this as there is the dawisha board and
they completely discredit him and that's
just the kind of thing that they didn't
know stays that reputation for going
after people who they thought were
working too public and so the Scientific
American gets them to the contest swing
and they they say okay nobody
understands what Einstein is saying so
let's give a lot of money to the person
who can best explain to the American
public when Einstein is saying and you
know that would have seemed like such an
interesting contest but it caught on and
we've got front-page coverage in the
newspapers so you have all these
contests that are becoming part of the
social fabric of the United States and
with Conan Doyle arising and with
everybody
and ghosts and ghosts then the
Scientific American have another idea
well what if we what if we conduct a
scientific study into the claim to the
Spiritualist that it's possible to
communicate with the dead let's try and
see if we can establish whether that can
be scientifically proven but let's do it
in the guise of the contest so Malcolm
Byrd who was one of the the Einstein
essay contest was his idea now his idea
to do this this basically the psychic
contest and so what they just what they
do is they they set up a judging
Commission of some of the top scientists
in America William McDougall who was the
chairman of psychology at Harvard was
one of the judges
but mcdougal was also the president of
the American Society of psychical
Research I mean it just shows you the
quality of Sciences at that time who had
taken an interest in in spiritualism and
psychic phenomena you know when upton
sinclair wrote a book called mental
radio which was about the psych
experiments that he was conducting on
his life Albert Einstein wrote the
introduction to it and you know these
there were Nobel prize-winning
scientists at this time who left there's
their fields and were devoting
themselves to trying to establish it you
know there was it's possible to prove
the existence of ghosts or the existence
of psychic phenomena
so mcdougal you know he represents that
sort of crossover between hard science
and psychic phenomena because he's
president of both the American Society
for psychical research and also Harvard
psychology there's another figure take
Daniel Comstock who was one of the great
physicists at MIT who has chosen to
judge and if mcdougal represented us
crossover between science and ghost
hauntings then Comstock represents the
crossover between science and
entertainment because Comstock was also
the person who founded Technicolor and
developed that that whole colorization
process that was just about to become
popular and
but he was also now the ghost hunter so
he was another one of the the judges
were chosen and the the other judge was
the sky in inherit Carrington who's sort
of a man after my own heart he he
introduced yoga to the United States who
was one of the people Judas do United
States he was a he wrote these books
about veganism and juice fasting you
know if you think is eccentric today to
like be or office this was not the 1920s
and you know he people thought he was
out of mind but he he was also known as
a really shrewd psychic detective you
know here up to the spiritualist
community in New York which is called
Lilydale
and he disguised himself as an old man
and he went to install all these
psychics and he wrote an expose of them
and was put on the front page of the New
York Times so he was considered a very
skilled psychic investigator he was one
of the judges walter prince who had
three degrees from Yale and had solved
what was called the Antigonish
poltergeist case in Canada you know is
this poltergeist that had supposedly
caused all these incredible things to
happen in this in this farm community
and Antigonish that's in Ontario and
Canada it's just such an algebraic place
but again it it became so famous in
America that you know they had to send
scientists up to Canada to study it and
walter prince unveiled it as a hoax
you know it was a young daughter and the
family who was causing all this
phenomena and so prince was probably
this time most famous psychic
investigator in america here with the
other judging contest the final judge
was Houdini who was considered the
world's expert on psychic fraud because
of the time he had spent as a false
medium and by this time he and conan
doyle were not getting along as well
anymore because Conan Doyle is the Conan
Doyle thought Houdini was a psychic
himself he believed does a lot of people
in the world did then that Houdini had
genuine supernatural powers and they
know nobody could explain some of the
things Houdini was able to do
but who Conan Doyle had by this time
they had a falling out and Houdini was
basically discrediting some of the
psychics that Conan Doyle had you know
had symptoms had sent him to so they
were getting along anymore but the
Scientific American knew they needed oil
because they knew no psychic would step
forward and enter this contest without
the imprimatur from from Conan Doyle so
bird goes to England and he talks Conan
Doyle but his time comes on back to
England he talks them into you know not
becoming a judge in the contest but you
know becoming somebody who would
advocate it and give it a you know his
stamp of approval so they're ready to
start the contest now they have the
judges and they basically the Scientific
American which is located in the
building down downtown they converted
their offices into these seance rooms
and so the only problem is they don't
really have a viable candidate and you
know this contest goes on for about a
year and a half and that you know they
test various mediums but they're so you
know they're not they're clearly not
genuine and I mean they can't find
anybody that they can even really test
seriously for a long period of time at
this point this young attractive Boston
woman named Nina Crandon had supposedly
discovered that that she was psychic
and the difference between Meena Crandon
and other psychics in America Meena
Kramden was married to a very
prestigious physician in Boston and you
know this time it was considered a
little disreputable to be a medium but
here is Meena Crandon who never took a
penny for her work who doesn't need the
prize money the Scientific American is
offering she's just going to donated
psychic research if she wins and she
purportedly has some some pretty
incredible abilities she goes to
Europe and and she just completely
douses all the best scientists in Europe
she sits with Conan Doyle and Conan
Doyle is amazed and you know people have
asked me some people ask me if you could
restage that what was that contest the
psychic contest if you could do it today
and what I always say is I don't really
think it's possible because what Mina
Kramden was doing she was a physical
medium
you know the Scientific American wasn't
interested in mental phenomena they
weren't interested in studying you know
whether or not you brought the name of
like you know whether or not a medium
could bring the name of like a you're
dead ends favorite cat you know they
didn't care about that they wanted to
see they weren't to test the kind of
medium who could make tables rise and
and cause objects to fly around the room
and who could use their psychic force
and to make things happen you know
things that are quantifiable by
scientific instruments and so she did
those kinds of things she would hold
these seances and as I mentioned
anything that wasn't tied down was was
liable to taint client and there would
be these these cold breezes that seemed
to come out of nowhere and voices would
be heard from various parts of the room
if she gave one seance in Boston and you
know five of the top doctors a test the
business that the table actually rose
and chased somebody out of the room and
down the hallway and and I know that
sounds crazy I don't know what happened
but all I can tell you is that all
everybody who was there saw the same
thing and so she does this kind of thing
in England she does it for Conan Doyle
and Conan Doyle suggests that she unto
the Scientific American contest and so
essentially
to make a long story short I don't want
to give away too much of the book she
she convinces a number she basically
convinces the entire committee
except for Houdini Houdini he you know
they Houdini and Meena by now she's by
the time the comment that she's called
Marjorie that was basically her stage
name because they wanted she wants to
protect her anonymity and you know most
of these other mediums they join the
Scientific American contest and they
enter the contest because they want to
become famous because they wanted to be
known as great because anything about
Marjorie didn't even want that attention
at least not at first
and so she and Houdini are basically
headed for a showdown because Marjorie
has sat with the rest of the scientists
they're about to give her this award
it's picked up by all the major
newspapers and that's what I was
mentioning this is the period summer of
24 where Marjorie's is on the front page
of these newspapers and essentially the
New York Times basically declares are
the first scientifically verified spirit
medium and history um she looks like
she's going to win this award and
Houdini is just appalled because he
hasn't sat with her yet so they called
him in and now develops one of the great
consultations I feel and one of the
great rivalries of the Jazz Age because
there is this sort of mythic tradition
of a male figure heroic male figure and
you know Houdini was given the same kind
of um heroic stature of a military hero
nay in those days of a male figure
having to confront a female sorceress it
goes back to Odysseus versus Circe and
King Arthur's versus Morgan let's say
you know she's going to use her
supernatural powers he you know he has
to stand up to it through his physical
prowess through his rectitude and what
Houdini believed is that she was the
seductress who who could seduce any man
and get them to do their bidding just
you know as Cersei did with
with Odysseus's men um and so their
their confrontation and their rivalry
has so many different levels to it
because in one sense it's kind of a
gender war you know Houdini has this
this vitality and this potency and but
you know what good is that in the dark
and the snail instead of learning you
know feeling that with it with this
woman but in the in those days most
psychics not all of them but but many of
them were women there is a sense that
that only women had the receptivity and
the sensitivity to be psychics but it
was really interesting because there was
a lot of roleplay going on in the seance
room somebody like Marjorie she went
into trance during her seances and she
would channel the spirit of her dead
brother and you know Mina was a number
of Boston society and so there were
certain things you know she just wasn't
allowed to do she couldn't swear she
wasn't what she did she kicked some
wasn't supposed to smoke or go to
speakeasies this is the time in
Massachusetts where women aren't even
allowed to sit in on juries and so
whenever she held seance
supposedly unconscious she would channel
the spirit of her brother and her
brother was this powerful very crude
incredibly vibrant presence people
sensed when that when they heard his
voice that he had more character and
more personality than the most of the
living people that were present and so
it isn't just Houdini versus Margery
it's the two Dini versus the male
expression of Margery or the the male
that Marjorie has channeled um the other
thing that's going on here
is and again this can go back to ancient
times if you want to take it far enough
you know in ancient Greece you know
psychics were there is the Oracle Delphi
they you know they were the religious
leaders and they were women or some say
the religious leaders but they were
religious figures and they were
they were channels but you know they
didn't really do anything they just sort
of went into trance and they took in
information and the priest would
translate for you know whoever was was
visiting the Oracle so um but when a
woman actually made things happen which
used her psychic power to cause objects
to fly around the room which used her
psychic power to seduce men well then
she's no longer a psychic then she's
been considered a witch and what Houdini
was trying to do I recognized when I was
researching this book you know there was
still this animus against witches in
this period of a witch had been burned
at the stake in in Ireland as recently
as 1912 we're talking here only 10 years
later and so you know what are the
traditional things that you accused
witches of well you accused them of
having this salacious sexuality and
Houdini accused Marjorie of sleeping
with basically every member of the
committee that it cleared of genuine and
you know just some really you know he
considered her a free lover um the other
thing you can see you accused witches of
during a witch trials you accused them
of Voodoo and Houdini told the
newspapers that Marjorie was practicing
black magic on him that he was he was
he'd made an effigy of him and she was
sticking needles in it that she was
conducting these satanic rituals now he
acted as me interesting thing about
Houdini he did it really he didn't say
that she she had black magic only that
she was involved with that you know this
he didn't think he actually had genuine
supernatural powers but you know he made
these these accusations all the
newspapers the third thing you accuse of
witches during which trial in even more
so than these other things I mentioned
is mischief with children and Houdini
and some reporters for the Boston Herald
are starting to I don't think I want to
reveal it but it I mean if you would
it's about it's horrible thing as you
can imagine some people would do with
children and basically these these
orphans
the Kramden Marjorie and her husband
miss Austin doctor they were bringing
over these orphans from England because
they wanted to adopt a male child but
apparently some of these orphans weren't
making it back to anyone so these were
all the things that Houdini was accusing
her of the orphan thing that this thing
of children was never he never at that
point he wasn't going after her about
that publicly but what Houdini was
trying to do was basically to which a
fire you know there is still this animus
against witches and in America in a
predominantly Christian country you know
mediumship and and witchcraft are
basically equated in the Bible and
Houdini is trying to turn a Christian
nation against Marjorie
by basically casting her as a witch in
the kremens sense exactly what was going
on and you know in Boston Massachusetts
of all places you know which has a rich
tradition of which persecution and which
mongering so um you know that this is
also a book about you know the
traditional rivalry between magicians
and witches because in medieval times it
was the magician's job to reverse the
spells of witches and to to trap them
basically so that's essentially to set
up this story and um I think I should
probably so yeah well
I just before you know we have I opened
up the questions right there are a few
people here tonight who I really want to
thank who who were involved with the
book my editor editor Domenico Alioto
has done a fantastic job and has been a
pleasure to work with I just wanted to
thank her for all she's done for the
book this is Rick Corrigan here tonight
Rick who was my first editor so I I have
a mushroom privilege as having had two
editors on this book because Rick is the
editor who first purchased the book who
first bought the book when he was a
crown and we worked together for years
and Rick did so much to help shape it
and then when Rick eventually left crown
he's now the vice president of Scribner
Dominica's took over the project and it
didn't miss a beat and I just I just
feel so lucky to have work with two of
the best editors and publishers enormous
book and I also want to thank Diana
Messina where are you he's just done so
much to get this balance of the world
he's the best publicist any writer could
could possibly hope for you know she's
done incredible work and I want to
acknowledge her and Danielle Crabtree
Danielle here somewhere I know your
figure Daniel he's in the back um she's
handled marketing for the book and it's
done just a magnificent job on that and
again I just loved every moment working
with her and I the other Tina Bennis I
don't know if she's here oh she's here
Tina so Tina's my agent and I can just
tell you this I've only worked with one
agent but I can honestly tell you she's
the best agent and in publishing and it
was Tina's idea to do this
the book I originally come to her with
some idea about astrology and you know
I've never written a book before and
basically every agent not approached had
you know you turned me away or want to
do something completely different with
it and so Tina kind of liked the idea
and at that time you know I was a
struggling screenwriter and she asked me
I think what my screenplay is were about
and I mentioned the sue Dini Margery
idea and we were just emailing at that
point but I could just imagine her eyes
line up for her responses because she
said look did this astrology thing maybe
that could be your second book write me
if you know writing me propose on
Houdini Margery and I promise you I'll
make you a huge book deal on it and you
know Tina is just she's just been
incredible and there would be no Witch
of lime sugar board for her and I don't
you know I think I'd still be an
astrologer and work for Tina so I want
to thank Tina the salon attack cast here
tonight I guess not so monitor oh some
mana if Tina's assistant and she's been
working on the project as well for all
these years I want to thank her and my
research assistant Warren flap he's he
has devoted so much time and energy to
this project as well so those are the
people I'd like to thank and you know we
can either do wine and cheese or we can
take some quickly you had a question I
sure do okay thank you David and
congratulations on the tree but I can't
wait to see what else you're spurred to
doing next a two-part question number
one how did you find this story or did
it find you what made you compel to
write about other than your agent and
the second part was there a story in
your research that you read about
Marjorie and/or Houdini that made the
hair on your arms and neck rise up and
gave you chills to the bones if it's in
the book a yes will suffice even left on
the cutting room floor what was
something in your research that gave you
the chills you know you asked me this
question once before but don't tell the
people at home
how could you weird that was after a few
drinks I okay so in regard to your your
first question and any and any Houdini
biography Marjorie is going to at least
make a cameo appearance you know she's
so sort of intertwined with the whole
Houdini mystique and when I first
encountered her in Houdini biography I
just I I kind of noticed feeling of just
sort of fallen in love with a character
being smitten by a character and
fascinated with a character and I
couldn't believe there hadn't been a
book about her you know this is not a
biography of Marjorie but um it you know
it is a book that deals largely with her
and I I just couldn't help but feel that
she deserved that sort of treatment
because the only people who are writing
about her will do sujini biographers who
you know saw her through Houdini's eyes
and I just never really thought she had
received fair treatment and also you
know I've been interested in the Jazz
Age and people don't associate occultism
with a Jazz Age it's just such a
fascinating prism through which to view
that period now there are a number of
things that just when I was researching
this I couldn't believe or gave me that
feeling you were talking about and I
have to say that when when I when I read
about it again and again I still can't
get over that initial seance I mentioned
earlier where I mean imagine that you're
sitting in a room and your hands or
you're sitting in a circle and the room
is pitch black and your hands are on the
table and you feel that the table start
to tremor and you feel that the energy
there's an energy imbued onto that table
and and it almost is becoming animate
it's it's starting to shift slightly and
then there is this sense of it it rising
and now somebody calls for red light so
they can see what's going on and in that
moment the table Rises it lurches
towards one particular person in the
room
and that person is so frightened he gets
up and leaves the room and the table
follows him no I again I've mentioned
this earlier all I can say is that
within a seance record which was signed
by five of the top physicians in Boston
there I I don't know what happened but I
mean that would scare me and so that
yeah that would be the moment that
stands out anybody else I'm sorry
Rebecca
um I existed in the bush and you know
we'll all read it but I was just we said
that Marjorie channeled her brother yeah
and I was just wondering if she lost him
in the war or what his story was no
that's a really good question I should
have clarified I so Marjorie's Houdini
was was very close to his mother and
devastated by her loss
Marjorie's the love of her life is
really her brother and one thing I'll
say about Marjorie she isn't who she
seems to be you know she married into
society she wasn't born in society her
brother was a railroad worker you know
incredibly handsome magnetic young man
and he died in this horrific railroad
axon and Marjorie was never you know
Marjorie had the sebou Lien's
she had this incredible spear and she
was always upbeat but she never really
recovered from that loss and know he did
it
Dadar and where he died in 1911 he but
he died shortly before the beginning of
the war so you know Houdini's mother
died in 1912 so for all of them you know
their loss happened around the war so
they could identify with the post-war
bereaved in people who had lost loved
ones during the war and you know one of
the things that people would comment on
who knew Walter was they kind of
understand if assuming that Margie was a
fake and you know in some ways if you
think Marjorie's a fake the story
becomes even more interesting because
Houdini would go before the public and
he would try to humiliate her and he
would try to demonstrate how he could do
through magic what she supposedly did
with her with her supernatural powers
but Houdini was the incredible
athlete you know the great magician in
the world how is the society why from
Boston able to do these things that only
a great magician should have been able
to do if it was fakery
so yeah an answer to your question her
yeah her brother did not die her in the
war but it was around the same period
and had the same effect on her as it did
other people who lost loved ones during
the war um yeah I personally about James
who was a believer in a different
religion but it did believe in the
communication with the dead under the
right circumstances and I just wondered
if you read what he was probably a
little too early for when your research
comes people did you read anything about
him so absolutely you can't write a book
about psychic phenomenon the other 20th
century without mentioning William James
because William McDougall the chairman
of Harvard psychology who became a judge
in the Scientific American concepts was
a protege of William James William James
headed Harvard psychology before
mcdougal you know William James you know
he died before the events in this book
take place but he was section in strong
influence because all the psychic
investigators wanted to be the next
William James you know he was considered
a great intellect in the United States
and when he started studying psychic
phenomena this was before the war before
there was this waves of dead in the
brief you know he got interested in a
point where it was more of an
intellectual interest but he ki he
became convinced that it was possible to
communicate with the dead and you know
he was as famed more famous for you know
the psychologist and his brother Henry
James was for his novel so he did a lot
so far as making psychic phenomena a
field which was palatable to University
study I mean the Harvard in those days
was the university that was most open
and most receptive to carrying on these
psychic experiments and it's all because
of William James
and there's certainly not that way
anymore
and also just this is deviating from
your point but um I started to make to
mention something before that I want to
finish that thought about what Marjorie
was doing William James study mental
phenomena he said he did study these
mediums who brought messages from the
dead he didn't really study physical
mediums Marjorie was a physical medium
and I'll just you know somebody again
somebody to ask me it was possible to -
we staged the Scientific American
concepts I don't think I ever finished
that thought the answer is there are no
physical mediums today who would be
willing to stand up to that kind of
public scrutiny the last one I know who
did this was on the Johnny Carson show I
think it was late the early 1960s a guy
named uri geller and he was able to
supposedly bend spoons through psychic
force and you know it's sort of a
testament to the decline in physical
mediumship because you know Marjorie was
was you know she would be put in the
spirit cabinet in the spirit comet would
just spontaneously combust around her
and you know she was as I mentioned
cause table to chase people and make
spirit light splash around rooms and you
know manifest apparitions and it's got
bending a spoon right you know Johnny
Carson was a magician and Johnny Carson
knew the tricks of magicians and so this
guy goes on a Johnny Carson szostak
every year might be like 1963 around
that period and Carson had consulted the
amazing Randi he's probably the most
well-known psychic debunker today and
he's in amazing Randi told them don't
let him anywhere near his own spoons you
supply the spoon and so caution it
sprays it basically was probably is
maybe the most awkward moment in
television history because it's you know
the entire country was watching his guys
on national television and everybody's
staring at the spoon and nothing's
happening
and um you know uri geller was
completely discredited after that and
what was that you know fifty years ago I
have yet to this will set Colby here
tonight yeah I mean she would know more
about this than I would Lisette
Lissette is the granddaughter one of the
great sidekicks of the same error is
Marjorie and her name is Eileen Garrett
and she she knew Margery and she makes a
cameo appearance in the book and Eileen
was the most well known physical meet
I'm sorry
mental medium of the time and Eileen I
think was a genuine medium so um but
what's that would know more about
physical mediums and what they're doing
today so you can talk to her but that
that would be my understanding is that
they're just if there are physical
mediums today they're not willing to a
movie in China in Germany Susan and I've
sat with him and seen his table zooming
around in his license is actually really
is that women yeah yeah interesting
it's quite the because I'm apart from my
psychic legacy I'm very skeptical
because the foundation that I leave that
was started by Garret wanted people to
apply scientific methodology to these
strange phenomena if she herself was
ambivalent about her own gifts and
wanted to know how she could do what she
could do so to actually see this stuff
for real and I even though I grew up in
it it's like I'm strange I'm still
trying to figure it out so I mean I say
having read a copy in galleries or
whatever of a book it's a fascinating
ride and I really congratulate you
there's an excellent excellent
and finally Eileen a grandmother
Eileen believed that Marjorie has
genuine supernatural powers she believes
she cheated sometimes but she also
believed that she was a genuine and
powerful psychic so there's that any
other
technology foundation the organization
that was established in 51 we have a
magnificent library that a
parapsychologist ambition Google can be
able to setting what delivery it's like
the one more question
Diane so what's the verdict you draw a
conclusion in your book is Marjorie a
fake or not does anybody else have a
question well then be I don't mean to I
will say this that I have gone through
such pains to write a book where I
really believe that you know it's about
presenting this case with a kind of
journalistic objectivity and I don't
want to I just feel that if I gave my
opinion as to whether or not Marjorie
was was was genuine or or whether she
was a fraud you know what we would
almost kind of destroy this whole or of
the book where it's not about me telling
people what I think
so I'm Robin with all that judgment but
there was somebody else had a
light-hearted questions like you know
who would you like to play the role of
Marjorie in a movie animation that's
funny because we're having that
conversation all the time and I not
Whoopi Goldberg please I you know
there's a the actress is that the thing
about Marjorie when you look at
photographs of her she doesn't look
stunningly beautiful does she every
contemporaneous account that you read
everybody goes on and on about her
beauty and how stunning she was and how
attractive she was and I think a lot of
it came from the inside and so when a
lot of actresses he's you know the names
are thrown around and they're they're
these people who just overtly beautiful
I it doesn't um it doesn't quite work
for me because I you know I think of
someone like Renee Zellweger who's
probably you know she's older than large
but you know when the role calls for it
she can be attractive and I I so I I
can't say there's one person I I
remember when I first heard about
Marjorie something about her reminded me
like of a young Jessica Lane but there
aren't a whole lot of actresses who I
can think of right now
who um yeah yeah I just can't think of
anyone do you I mean you have any idea I
can't Eliska or she's the one that
started in a royal affair and she's been
in like five movie this year but she's
at X macking that she was in that she's
amazing she's Danish but rather there no
the only of it I've always been partial
with your handsome David congratulations
that was an incredible presentation
thank you so much for coming
thanks to book TV David will be over on
this corner signing books so it would be
kind of a a line like this we have a
reception planned if you can when you
get up fold your chair put it against
the wall that will open up the whole
space you get let me enter you can eat
and thanks again for coming
now I am
you're watching book TV nonfiction
authors